you know BP when you think about it has
had a series of of problems ah you might
say it was a gutsy thing for a company
who had you know 99 percent of what they
sell is petroleum to say we're going to
be beyond petroleum now when they made
that announcement I was rooting for them
to win but it was a pretty audacious
claim to make and clearly not a claim
they were willing to stick with because
shortly thereafter they started getting
out of the alternative energy business
and wasted hundreds of millions of
dollars claiming to be something that
they really were not ready to be but
then they had a terrible explosion at a
plant in Texas that killed some of their
workers then of course they've had this
tremendous spill in the Gulf Mexico
there is a series of patterns which goes
back to the issue of what kind of
culture do we have what kind of culture
do we have that we ignore the questions
that must arise inside the company about
the the the the this intelligence to do
some of the things that we're doing that
to me is a sign of a culture where those
questions are repressed those questions
aren't answered and a handful of people
are allowed to continue to do the wrong
thing because they ignore the challenges
that are raised internally and I think
that that BP you know is a metaphor in a
lot of ways I mean I think about this
oil spill which is a very visible
representation of the way that we're
abusing the environment but it's really
no difficult different than the way we
handle chemicals we have an open spicket
through which millions of pounds of
toxic
chemicals are dumped into our society
into the air into the ground water
through our products it just happened to
be invisible the effects are still there
increased asthma rates increased cancer
rates and children but we have many oil
spills whether they're chemicals whether
they're petroleum and and this goes back
to the notion that we as a society and
particularly we as businesses have all
the warning signs of what's ahead you
know how many more spills do we need how
many more earthquakes do we need or
volcanoes or or hurricanes I mean the
earth in a sense is telling us you can't
keep doing this there is a price that is
going to be paid for your behavior
I don't know whether Tony Hayward has
children but if he does I bet he's
getting an earful from his children
about how embarrassing it is to go to
school every day as the child of the
president of BP we should not
underestimate the pressure that that
brings on CEO and senior management BP
today is not a company you want to tell
people you work for when you show up at
a party so so there is a part of this
social pressure that will come to bear
on the company but we also need to hold
the government accountable the
government has has has totally
historically not held these oil
companies accountable for their
responsibilities as we see with the
mineral Management Agency we need to
support NGOs because often it is
pressure from groups like Greenpeace
which I'm a board member of that will
help tilt the scale look you know you
won't catch me buying gas at a BP
station probably for the rest of my life
and I think that it is this combination
of factors it's pressure from the
government pressure from the NGOs
pressure from their internal employees
as well as what we can do as individuals
you know you may think that in this day
and age writing letters and emails
doesn't make a difference it does I can
tell you is a business owner and manager
when someone writes a letter I know that
there's probably a hundred if not a
thousand people that feel the same way
that that person felt and that carries a
lot of weight it's not one letter or one
email it is a representation of hundreds
or thousands of people who feel the same
way
the challenge of moving the commitment
to sustainability beyond senior
management is ultimately a cultural
challenge you have to send that message
you have to incentivize people you know
if you pay out bonuses based upon
increased sales and profits and not
sustainability initiatives where will
people put their attention on profits
and sales so you have to embed these
ideas and incentives within your culture
you have to reward people that are
sustainability leaders not just the
biggest sales people and so it is
ultimately a cultural challenge and you
need to design your culture to function
and be aligned with your sustainability
objectives which also means that
ultimately it has to be embedded in
corporate strategy the only way to be
really responsible and really
sustainable is if it's part of your
strategy as a company it can't exist in
a compartment it really doesn't work to
have a sustainability corporate
responsibility police person who ensures
that everybody else at the company is
responsible that sense of responsibility
has to live in everybody that works in
the company in every department in the
strategies and goals and objectives of
every department in every person